welcome welcome to this video playing
our 5-minute game and turn let's play
the calc on and dry up probably will you
gather isolated oh no Knight c3 this is
quite unusual hmm yeah how to learn how
to play that now I can just take before
I don't know I don't really want to
close the position at some let's open
this up and ce4 zone a rather strange
move on the structure I could even think
about playing if I p.m. yeah why not
let's prevent deform if he goes Knight
f3 I can maybe consider f5 this is a bit
risky looking though a 5mm f5 and you
fall very ambitious and on f5 he might
go nite xe5 takes on e4 Queen h5 check
this kind of tactic you always need to
consider on night XD five i also have
Queen his heaven though ok let's try
that but some one of those don't try
this at home moves her ok 9527 was
probably okay I'm not sure that he even
considered it ok before now this was the
idea gaining lots of space
oh yeah this is very passive I thought
95
and 95 quindi for would have been
interesting okay but no that's not think
too much about that that's gone continue
to play Knight f6 yeah no I'm actually
even threatening f4 which would push
right back enormously you cannot play d4
because of the check here or maybe you
can we should be to it can play but d4 I
can also just then just take yeah but he
needs to do that I think deform you know
since I was thinking I could check here
but should be to a sir perfectly okay
is there some technical way to go about
that night official before JP should be
to f4 or something probably not you can
take before
okay let's just develop this piece maybe
still have a forum on the agenda and
okay just prepare castling yeah not a
bad move but i think i should i maybe
should have thought a bit longer when i
am when i was considering um Knight f6 I
could have taken or maybe I should have
taken actually I still have f four miles
was stupid counseling and okay not that
I'm bad or bad off here but should have
considered it a bit at least Kim my g4
must be good attack the special it
doesn't have a good square we should be
three or so bit strange yeah this now
invites various ideas one of them's
Bishop before Queen takes 93 or just
cake III which is not that bad at all I
can also consider Queen edge form or
queen c7
yeah that's all good actually they're
all good
Quincy 727 ever thanks fun even g5 is a
move which looks am rather rather
strange and I'm sleeping here head
spending spending ages on this position
which is completely unnecessary okay
check let's see that the King moves
Queen d2 Bishop before so I cannot
castle anymore ok and now let's drop
back attack f1 so he needs to play 92
and this really your hand process
development make sure that c4 c5 is not
coming he cannot take so ok let's get
the knight to f6 I'm always attacking f4
so it cannot really move the night only
to end the the consequences if you
cannot move the night how will you have
a move to have one bishop not at all I
guess yeah this makes it very difficult
to to do anything here so I'd I just go
here good good square and then I'm
preparing Bishop d7 and then be five
opening up the Queen side yeah he's
trying to to maybe put this on h1 and
play G floor but I'm on g4 very often
maybe you can drop back clayji 3 and so
on very yeah very long and complicated
maneuver I just try if he takes 95 to
get that form
won't be too
the B file is not not bad at all
now i don't know maybe I had something
even more convincing but it looks looks
rather nice I was spending so much time
for for basically nothing that I need to
be quick here not think so much about
the best move but be okay with just
playing a good news not sure that Rob c2
was a good movie really okay so let's
get the Queen involved and rook eight to
be too this may be possible now on
something else Queen d2 I go route be to
this 91 which is a bit bit bit ugly
let's get rid of the Queen's iam the
queen is also blocking on e3
get g5 into the into the mix down to 27
seconds so I can take a plane either
phone but it's not so much of a problem
hi morning yeah I need to break through
quickly him check king king of five and
G floors check very powerful check check
I stopped the deep bone unfortunately
these bones are powerful like four if
it's on time I get at the end team he
fall faded on time um yeah my time
management was a catastrophe but damn i
think maybe around here he shouldn't you
should actually survived so long but
then i needed to play a play quickly
yeah here g5 for example this is a
computer suggestion yeah yeah if you got
110 on the clock want to play quickly g
g5 is just but it's very useful to see
and look at this g5 it's just very
instructive you would take it attack on
the weakest spot on there for and yeah
what cannot take losses the house and
then we get doesn't have a move room to
protect that for computer wants to play
Knight h1 great so black is just
breaking through on f4
and yeah I didn't didn't spend any time
he had just play Bishop d7 I well guess
i could have seen it but this would have
been much quicker and around here he s
g32 to cover it but then next thing I
was kept some some advantage alright
thanks for watching